Have you guys heard
of the term sharenting?
-No.
-Er, sharenting? No.
Sharing about being a parent?
Those parents that share everything
about their children online?
Sharenting.
It's something that I do
quite regularly to be honest.
People come to this country,
they haven't been back,
they have kids
and make their life here.
Some of my family back home
have never seen them before.
If I didn't put them on social
media they wouldn't see them.
Sometimes I get really embarrassed
when my mum posts stuff
on her Facebook page
or her Instagram or whatever,
very embarrassing.
Very.
-Very?
-Mmm.
They might not want their friends
to see them that way.
They want to have some kind
of control over their image.
There's a famous case
of Gwyneth Paltrow
posting a picture of her daughter
Apple and it was a selfie.
There was nothing really, you would
think, contentious about it,
yet her daughter
complained about it.
Wow, I'd be in trouble.
They're posting about people
who are not themselves
and that could impact us
when we go out into the real world
and try to get a job, for example.
There is an element of trust there
between a parent and a child
I'm not comfortable with
my face being shown
without me knowing what actually I'm
being perceived as on their platform.
It may not seem like something
which is particularly significant.
It may be very personally
upsetting to individuals
what parents put up on the internet.
For people of our generation,
your online identity isn't
so much seen as separate
from your real-life identity
but just an extension of it.
Social media profiles
are identity projects.
I don't think that the government
as well as parents
should take control
over our online identities
because it is a part of who we are
and we use our posts and stuff
like that to express ourselves.
-It draws attention to
the kind of complex everyday work
that those posts are doing
which are not about showing off.
Sharenting isn't new. Those of us
that can remember cringy moments
seeing kids' photo albums
handed around to friends and family
know all too well that this
is a fairly fundamental urge
on behalf of parents to share
their pride about their children.
It's a way of showing that
you're doing that parenting.
What is new about sharenting in
the digital context is of course that
we are leaving a fairly extensive
and lengthy digital stream
of photos, comments, stories.
We didn't want to invade her privacy,
even though she's just a baby.
That's going to stay online forever.
Any image you post now is going
to be on the internet forever
and then we don’t know what's
going to happen in the future
with things coming up like deepfake
and you're just
giving your kid's image away.
Especially now with
face-recognition software
by posting facial images online
you're helping them
create a database.
You don’t know how these images that
you've posted are going to be used.
Unfortunately we have
paedophile groups who will literally
sort of scan videos
to take out single shots
which seem to expose parts
of a child's body or--
And that's a horrifying thought
so I think a lot of this is about
education and changing social norms.
One of the strategies that I use is
taking pictures of them when they're
not actually facing the camera
so you can't see her face.
These new digital tools enable
us to look back on
nice moments from
our child's early days,
early years, development, etc.
Funny little things that you write
on there and then it's like,
"Oh yeah that happened then,
like a whole year ago."
It's pretty good to let
all her friends know that
I did this, oh,
I went to this school and like,
knowing that, oh like,
I'm really happy.
If sharenting is done
in a responsible way
and it enables families
to have conversations,
for example with their kids
as they get older
about what you want to have online,
how you portray yourself,
then actually I think it can
be a really important step
towards keeping kids themselves safe
as they become
digitally enabled adults.